we will now consider an operation that
is in some sense the opposite of merging
we have a node and traffic arrives to
that node and each time that we have an
arrival we flip a coin and with
probability Q we send that arrival to
one particular stream and with
probability 1 minus Q we send the
arrival to another stream so we get two
streams that are formed by taking the
original stream and splitting it into
two pieces and as an example these might
be arrivals at the department store and
the one stream corresponds the people
who go to the clothes section of the
department store whereas the other
stream corresponds to the people that go
to all of the other sections of the
store so let us now make our model a
little more precise we have a Bernoulli
process which is independent across time
we also use independent coin flips an
independent coin flip to deal with each
one of the arrivals but we will also
make one additional assumption namely
that the Bernoulli process is also
independent from the process of coin
flips with this assumption in place let
us now continue and let us draw a
picture we have a Bernoulli process with
parameter P and arrivals get recorded at
certain times each time that there is an
arrival we will flip a coin and with
probability Q the arrival will be sent
to that stream with probability 1 minus
Q the arrival will be sent to the other
stream so one possible outcome of the
experiment might be this one word these
two arrivals were sent to the stream and
these two arrivals were sent to the top
stream and we have these probabilities Q
and 1 minus Q of sending the arrivals to
one or the other stream what kind of
process is this one we argue that it is
a Bernoulli process
first we need to check independence here
the argument is more or less the same as
in the case when we studied the merging
of processes for example if we look at
two different slots and we ask how is
the event at that slot and that slot
determined well what happens in this
slot is determined by whether we had an
arrival here and what happened to the
outcome of the coin flip at that time
what happens in this slot is determined
by whether we had an arrival here and
what happened to the coin flip at that
time now the coin flips are independent
from the original Bernoulli process and
for either the coin flips or the
Bernoulli process we have independence
across time so all of the four random
variables involved here that determines
what happens in these two slots are
independent of each other so what
happens in this slot is a function of
two random variables here which are
independent from the two random
variables that determine what happens in
that slot so what happens in these two
slots are independent events and this
argument goes through more generally
when we consider multiple distinct slots
so this is the argument for the
independence of the different slots in
this particular process and then during
each slot what happens is that we will
have an arrival if and only if this
process records an arrival which happens
with probability P and the corresponding
coin flip happened to send the arrival
in this direction which happens with
probability Q and so the conclusion is
that this process is a Bernoulli process
with parameter P times Q by a similar
argument the other process that we
obtain will also be Bernoulli but with
probability P times 1 minus Q and the
final question are these two processes
that we get after the splitting
independent of each other this is a
question that we can answer by reasoning
into it
if I tell you that there was an arrival
in this slot what can you infer from
this well it tells me that there was an
arrival in the original stream which was
sent here but since it was sent in this
direction it means that it was not sent
in the other direction and so we do not
have an arrival in this slot knowing
that we have an arrival here means that
we do not have an arrival there so
information about one of the streams
gives us information about what happened
in the other stream and therefore we do
not have independence so this is what
happens when we split to Bernoulli
processes and earlier we saw what
happens when we merge two independent
Bernoulli processes these two operations
of merging and splitting are quite
common in constructing more complex
models using Bernoulli processes as the
elements of those models they are often
useful models either in transportation
systems where you have streams of
traffic that merge or split also in
models of computer networks or any other
kind of chewing system and these same
operations of merging and splitting will
also show up when we study the
continuous-time analogue of the
Bernoulli process namely the Poisson
process